This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the early 1940s, as the war ever ramped up, the Navy put out a proposal for chairs. They needed a chair that was fireproof, waterproof, lightweight, and strong enough to survive a torpedo blast. An engineer named Wilton C. Dengis designed a chair he knew would be perfect. A chair made out of aluminum. Wilton Dengis developed a method, a process to take this aluminum and bend it and weld it and grind it and heat treat it.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在 20 世纪 40 年代初，随着战争日益激化，美国海军发布了一份关于椅子的提案。他们需要一种防火、防水、轻便，并且坚固到足以承受鱼雷爆炸冲击的椅子。一位名叫威尔顿·C·登吉斯的工程师设计了一款他确信完美无缺的椅子。一款由铝制成的椅子。威尔顿·登吉斯开发了一种方法、一种工艺，将这种铝材进行弯曲、焊接、打磨和热处理。
All of these elements, they're all invisible but part of making something that's super strong. That's Greg Buntbinder. He knows this chair inside and out. It's the most indestructible chair on the planet. Wulton Dinger's proved this by taking his super strong indestructible aluminum chair up to the eighth floor of the Excelsior Hotel in Chicago where the Navy was holding chair auditions and he threw it out the window. And hit the sidewalk and bounced several times. I am retroactively terrified by this whole story.
所有这些元素，它们虽然都是看不见的，但却是打造超强坚固产品的一部分。那是格雷格·邦德宾德。他对这款椅子了如指掌。这是地球上最不可摧毁的椅子。威尔顿·登吉斯通过将他这款超强、不可摧毁的铝制椅子带到芝加哥埃克塞尔西奥酒店的八楼（海军当时在那里举行椅子甄选会），然后把它从窗户扔了下去，以此证明了这一点。它砸在人行道上，反弹了好几次。我对这个故事的整体经历感到后怕。
Someone ran the cheer back up and it was completely perfect, undamaged. The Navy was impressed and they gave Wilton Dengis a huge contract. In order to fill this contract, he opened a huge factory. And he called his business the electrical machine and equipment company, or Emico. That's my fellow radio-topian Benjamin Walker, host of the Theory of Everything podcast. Benjamin reported this story.
有人把这把椅子拿了回来，它完全完好无损，没有丝毫损坏。海军印象深刻，并与威尔顿·登吉斯签下了一份大合同。为了履行这份合同，他开办了一家巨大的工厂。他将自己的公司命名为电气机械设备公司，简称 Emico。那是我的广播乌托邦同行本杰明·W·沃克，《万物理论》播客的主持人。本杰明报道了这个故事。
Over the next few decades, Emico shipped hundreds of thousands of these 1006 Navy chairs to the US government from its factory in Hanover, Pennsylvania. It became standard issue for all warships, battleships, aircraft carriers, um, submarines. It's aluminum, silver, modern and minimal, not too many flourishes. It doesn't even have arms, just three slats coming down from the back. The top is arched, but it's squared off a bit on the sides. It's a utilitarian looking design, except it has one slightly unexpected enhancement.
在接下来的几十年里，Emico 从其位于宾夕法尼亚州汉诺威的工厂向美国政府运送了数十万把这种 1006 型海军椅。它成为了所有军舰、战列舰、航空母舰以及潜艇的标准装备。它是铝制的，银色，现代且极简，没有太多花哨的装饰。它甚至连扶手都没有，只有三根从靠背向下延伸的板条。顶部呈拱形，但在两侧稍微有些方正。这是一个实用主义的设计，除了有一个稍微意想不到的改进之外。
There's a divot on the seat for your butt. In the 1970s, Emico was purchased by a California businessman named J. Buckbinder. That's Greg's father. But by the 1990s, the company was losing a lot of money. So Greg took a trip to the factory to check on things. When he got there, things looked really bleak for Emico. It was a skeleton crew and the guys were just waiting for the company to close. The government contracts had long dried up.
座面上有一个为你屁股准备的凹坑。在 20 世纪 70 年代，Emico 被一位名叫 J·巴克宾德的加州商人收购。那是格雷格的父亲。但到了 90 年代，公司损失惨重。于是格雷格去工厂视察情况。当他到达时，Emico 的情况看起来非常黯淡。那里只有一班骨干员工，大家都在等待公司倒闭。政府订单早已枯竭。
Greg started to think perhaps this place should be shut down. But then, he overheard a phone call between the office manager, Paulina, and a mystery customer. She was on the phone and she said, no, we will not chip your chairs. You ship us, you send us some money first and slam the phone down and I said, Paulina, who is that? She saw some guy, George Yomani. And she had no idea who that was.
格雷格开始思考，也许这个地方应该关门大吉了。但随后，他无意中听到办公室经理宝琳娜和一个神秘客户之间的电话交谈。她在电话里说，不，我们不会运送你的椅子。你得先把钱汇给我们，把钱寄过来，然后狠狠地挂断了电话。我对她说，宝琳娜，那是谁？她看到了某个叫乔治·约马尼的人。而她根本不知道那是谁。
And I started to look through the file cameras of who we were shipping chairs to. They were shipping chairs to designers like Georgiom Armani and Terence Conrad and hip entrepreneurs like Ian Schrager. Wealthy tastemakers had discovered the beauty of these indestructible Navy surplus chairs. Greg suddenly realized that Emico could sell to what was mostly an untapped market. I just felt right at that time if we can shift our focus from government sales to focus on architects and designers, that would be an opportunity for us to take this thing and turn it around.
我开始翻阅我们向谁发货椅子的档案相机。他们一直在向乔治·阿玛尼（Georgio Armani）和特伦斯·康兰（Terence Conran）等设计师以及伊恩·施拉格（Ian Schrager）等时尚企业家运送椅子。富有的潮流引领者们发现了这些坚不可摧的海军闲置椅的美。格雷格突然意识到，Emico 可以向一个基本上未被开发的市场销售产品。我当时就觉得，如果我们能将重心从政府销售转到建筑师和设计师身上，这将是我们抓住机会扭转局势的契机。
Greg Buckbinder definitely turns things around. Today, Emiko makes new chairs with architects and designers like Norman Foster, Frank Geary, and Philippe Stark. And the original 1006 Navy chair has become one of the most iconic chairs in the world. You've definitely seen it before. It's in all kinds of movies and TV shows. It can be seen in the Matrix and Avatar. And a polstered version shows up in the Dark Knight when Batman interrogates the Joker.
格雷格·巴克宾德确实扭转了局面。如今，Emico 与诺曼·福斯特、弗兰克·盖里和菲利普·斯塔克等建筑师和设计师合作生产新椅子。最初的 1006 海军椅已经成为世界上最具标志性的椅子之一。你绝对见过它。它出现在各种电影和电视节目中。它出现在《黑客帝国》和《阿凡达》中。当蝙蝠侠审讯小丑时，《黑暗骑士》中也出现了一款带靠垫的版本。
It's the chair you see and seen set in prisons and police stations. It's also a go-to chair for fancy restaurants and art galleries and co-working spaces. It's everywhere. But not all of these chairs are emico chairs. A lot of them are knockoffs, fakes. How can you tell if they're real? Oh, you can see the slide at the bottom, it curves. See the bottom, slide?
这是你在监狱和警察局布景中经常看到的椅子。它也是高级餐厅、艺术画廊和联合办公空间的常用椅子。它无处不在。但并非所有这些椅子都是 Emico 椅子。其中许多是山寨货、假货。你怎么能看出它们是真的呢？哦，你可以看到底部的滑轨，它是弯曲的。看到底部滑轨了吗？
I have these. Last month, Benjamin walked me around New York City, showing me both real and fake emico chairs, like the fancy diner filled with real Mico chairs near his apartment in the East Village. And that's nice chairs and wood, and it's full of people. They look wealthy. Then, Benjamin took me to his place to show me his collection of real and fake Mico. This is the first knockoff that I was kind of excited about because if you lift it up
我有这些。上个月，本杰明带我参观了纽约市，向我展示了真假 Emico 椅子，比如他东村公寓附近那家摆满了真 Mico 椅子的豪华餐馆。那里的椅子很漂亮，是木制的，里面坐满了人。他们看起来很富有。然后，本杰明带我去了他的住处，向我展示了他的真假 Mico 收藏。这是让我有点兴奋的第一个山寨货，因为如果你把它抬起来
you'll see that there's something immediately wrong. Okay. What's heavy? It's not even made of aluminum. Benjamin Walker is obsessed with the real and the fake. What makes something real and when does it matter? These are questions he's exploring right now in a miniseries on his show, The Theory of Everything. And for 99% invisible, I wanted to look at the real
你会发现有些地方立刻就不对了。好吧。什么很重？它甚至不是铝制的。本杰明·沃克对真品和赝品着迷。是什么让某样东西成为真的，这又在什么时候重要？这些是他目前在他的节目《万物理论》的一个迷你系列中探讨的问题。对于 99% Invisible，我想看看真实的
and the fake as they relate to the design of chairs. In America today, most people think of design as shape. The average consumer doesn't realize the design is so much more than that. To understand what a real amico is, you need to understand not just what it looks like, but how it's made. There are 77 steps we go through to produce the navy chair. That's why I took a visit to the factory in Pennsylvania. The first step, actual sheets of aluminum, this sheet is the sheet we'll use to make
与虚假的与椅子设计的关系。在当今的美国，大多数人认为设计就是形状。普通消费者没有意识到设计远不止于此。要了解什么是真正的 Emico，不仅需要了解它的外观，还需要了解它的制造过程。生产海军椅我们要经历 77 个步骤。这就是我访问宾夕法尼亚州工厂的原因。第一步，实际的铝板，这张铝板就是我们将用来制作
seat bottoms from. One of the most distinctive elements of an Emico Navy chair is the butt-shaped divot. Legend has it, it was modeled after the dareer of Betty Grable, a famous Hollywood actress of the 1940s. But there's absolutely no evidence for this claim. Growing up, and friends would come over to our house and get the giggles about the butt shape in the scene. That's Jay Buckbinder. She was named for her grandfather, Greg's father, and she recently started working at Emiko.
座椅底部的板材。Emico 海军椅最鲜明的特色之一就是那个臀部形状的凹坑。传说它是以 20 世纪 40 年代好莱坞著名女演员贝蒂·格拉布尔（Betty Grable）的臀部为蓝本制作的。但完全没有证据支持这种说法。在我成长过程中，朋友们来我家时，总是会为场景中的屁股形状发出咯咯的笑声。那是杰伊·巴克宾德。她是以祖父的名字命名的（格雷格的父亲），她最近开始在 Emico 工作。
Oh man. Now we're off to welding. I didn't see much automation at the emico factory, just a number of very skilled craft people. This is Walt and right now he's routing holes into the aluminum extruded tube in order to accept cross bars that go into the tube. In this case, the famous three vertical slats. The back of the emico chair is curved like an upside down U. And the three vertical slats come down from the top of this U and meet a curved crossbar. The three slats don't go all the way to the seat.
天哪。现在我们要去焊接了。我在 Emico 工厂没有看到太多的自动化，只有许多非常熟练的工匠。这是沃尔特，现在他正在铝挤压管上钻孔，以便容纳插入管中的横杆。在这个例子中，就是著名的三根垂直板条。Emico椅子的背部像一个倒U形弯曲。三根垂直板条从这个U形的顶部向下延伸，与一根弯曲的横杆相交。这三根板条并没有一直延伸到座位。
They intersect with the crossbar, three quarters of the way down. It's one of the most distinctive design elements of the emico shape. OK, so now we're going over to Department 3, which is grinding. All the wells have to be ground down except three. The original chair they made for the Navy had a lump of welding at each joint. But when the fancy designers started working with Imico, they found all the welds to be a little crude, so Imico ground them down, except for the three welds where the vertical slats meet the arch
它们与横杆在四分之三的高度处相交。这是 Emico 外形最鲜明的设计元素之一。好的，现在我们要去 3 号车间，也就是打磨车间。除了三个焊点外，所有的焊缝都必须打磨掉。他们为海军制作的原版椅子在每个接合处都有一个焊接凸起。但当大牌设计师开始与 Emico 合作时，他们发现所有的焊缝都有点粗糙，于是 Emico 将它们磨平了，除了垂直板条与拱形交汇处的三个焊缝
on the back of the chair. We leave these three welds on the back as our signature. After the chairs have gone through all this heavy work, they go through a series of water baths. There's a total of five baths, one, two, three, four, five in order to perfect this process. After five salt baths in a night and at 320 degree oven, this aluminum chair is three times stronger than steel. It's the ultimate in sustainability and kind of the opposite of planned-up salessence.
在椅子的背面。我们在背部保留这三个焊缝作为我们的标志。在椅子经历了所有这些繁重的加工之后，它们会经过一系列水浴。总共有五次水浴，一、二、三、四、五，以完善这个工艺。经过五次盐浴和一个晚上的 320 度烤箱烘烤后，这把铝制椅子比钢坚固三倍。它是可持续性的极致，某种程度上是计划报废的对立面。
Many of the designers who work with emico want to see this elaborate process and make the trip out to Pennsylvania to meet the workers, like the famous industrial designer, Philippe Stark, whose visit was filmed by Greg. I was obliged for myself to meet you, because like artists, you make a sculpture, and you reproduce the sculpture every day by 100 and by Sao Zanda. And that it's a beauty. That's why when you see your chair, you see love. According to Greg, when designers visit the factory, they come away with a deeper appreciation
许多与 Emico 合作的设计师都想亲自看看这套复杂的工艺，并特意前往宾夕法尼亚州拜访工人们，比如著名的工业设计大师菲利普·斯塔克（Philippe Stark），他的造访被格雷格拍摄了下来。我不得不亲自去见你们，因为就像艺术家一样，你们制作了一件雕塑，并且每天复制这件雕塑 100 次甚至上千次。这就是美。这就是为什么当你看到你们的椅子时，你能感受到爱。据格雷格说，当设计师参观工厂时，他们会对工人们
of the workers and the value of the chair, beyond its shape. When I take an architect through Emico, the one thing that they always say is you should charge more for this chair. A lot of architects must have a pretty big chair budget because Emico chairs are not inexpensive. A new 1006 Navy chair will set you back about $550. But you can get an emico look-alike chair for a lot less. There are several websites that have listings from vendors of fakes, counterfeit chairs. That's Madsen Bookfinder, Greg's wife.
以及椅子超越其形状的价值产生更深的赞赏。当我带建筑师参观 Emico 时，他们总是说的一句话是，你们这把椅子应该卖贵一点。许多建筑师一定有相当丰厚的椅子预算，因为 Emico 椅子并不便宜。一把崭新的 1006 海军椅大约要花你 550 美元。但你可以花少得多的钱买到一把外形相似的 Emico 椅子。有几个网站列出了销售仿冒品、假冒椅子的供应商。那是马德森·布克宾德，格雷格的妻子。
She does press for the company, but she also has this ritual where she wakes up every morning and scours a number of e-commerce sites for fakes. And those sites are house and eBay, Amazon and Alibaba. We have very good luck if it's an exact copy. I can get those off in a heartbeat. When companies don't comply with their requests to take down the look alike, Emago can take the company to court. This is what happened in 2012, when restoration hardware started selling the Naval Chair. They even knocked off the name. So when someone is a counter-fitter, that's typically the kind of things they do in order to give their product fake authenticity.
她负责公司的公关工作，但她也有这样一个习惯：每天早上醒来，都会在一些电商网站上搜寻假货。这些网站包括 House、eBay、Amazon 和 Alibaba。如果是精准复制，我们通常会有很好的运气。我可以立马把它们下架。当公司不遵守他们下架山寨货的要求时，Emico 可以将该公司告上法庭。这就是 2012 年发生的事情，当时 Restoration Hardware 开始销售海军椅。他们甚至连名字都山寨了。所以当有人是造假者时，这通常是他们为了赋予其产品虚假真实性而做的事情。
Restoration hardware settled with Emico before the case went to court. Greg's also gotten other big box companies like Target and Ikea to knock it off with the knock-offs. He can do this because he has trade dress protection. Trade dress protection is designed to protect consumers from the look-alike imitations of name brand products. It's not protecting the function or use of the product. It's just the dress, how it looks, and for Emico, that means the chair's shape. That shape belongs to Emico.
Restoration Hardware 在案件上法庭之前与 Emico 达成庭外和解。格雷格还让塔吉特（Target）和宜家（Ikea）等其他大型零售巨头停止销售山寨货。他之所以能做到这一点，是因为他拥有商业外观保护。商业外观保护旨在保护消费者免受名牌产品外观仿冒的侵害。它不保护产品的功能或用途。它只是保护外观、看起来怎么样，对 Emico 来说，这意味着椅子的形状。那个形状属于 Emico。
Nobody can reproduce that shape. So having that kind of protection allows us to be very aggressive when we need to be. But I met a lawyer, Christopher Sprigman, who doesn't think Emico deserves this protection. So consumers in the marketplace, when they look at this chair, unless they are real furniture-efficient autos, they don't think, oh, this is Amaco. They think, oh, that's a chair, right? Or that's a pretty chair, or that chair would look good in my living room.
没有人可以复制那个形状。因此，拥有这种保护使我们在必要时能够非常激进。但我遇到了一位律师克里斯托弗·斯普里格曼（Christopher Sprigman），他认为 Emico 不配获得这种保护。所以市场上的消费者，当他们看着这把椅子时，除非他们是真正的家具行家，否则他们不会想，哦，这是 Emico。他们会想，哦，这是一把椅子，对吧？或者这是一把漂亮的椅子，或者这把椅子放在我的起居室里会很好看。
I don't think that the shape of this chair is distinctive. It's an office chair design that's been around. I have pictures of it from the 20s and department stores and offices. If this had gone to litigation, I think that would have become clear. Trade dress protection is really hard to get for designed products. And Christopher Sprigman believes if Emico ever does end up in court,
我不认为这把椅子的形状具有独特性。这是一种历来有之的办公室椅子设计。我有它 20 年代在百货公司和办公室里的照片。如果这真的闹上法庭，我认为这一点就会变得很清楚。商业外观保护对于设计产品来说真的很难获得。克里斯托弗·斯普里格曼认为，如果 Emico 最终真的走上法庭，
it risks losing this protection. What really bothers Christopher is companies like Emico, in Herman Miller, and Beatra, turning to the law to take knockoffs out of the marketplace. To the extent that that succeeds, these designs become the territory of the rich and no one else can access them. But I just wanna put a fine point on this. So this is a family company that's their business and I understand that they care about that.
它将面临失去这种保护的风险。真正让克里斯托弗烦恼的是像 Emico、Herman Miller 和 Vitra 这样的公司，利用法律将山寨货赶出市场。从这种做法成功的程度来看，这些设计将成为富人的领地，其他人将无法接触到它们。但我只想明确一点。所以这是一个家族企业，这是他们的生意，我理解他们对此很在意。
But let me just say that out there in the world, there are a bunch of consumers who want to furnish their homes. And you know, this is a country where not everyone is rich. And if you want to be stylish and have a house that's nice and you don't have a ton of money, you might buy knockoff chairs. In his book, The Knockoff Economy,
但请让我说，在世界各地，有一群消费者想要装饰他们的家。你知道，这是一个并非每个人都富有的国家。如果你想赶时髦，拥有一所漂亮的房子，又没有一大笔钱，你可能会买山寨椅子。在他的书《山寨经济》中，
Christopher makes the argument that these kinds of protections given to expensive things like chairs and clothing is actually bad for consumers. Because for most people, knockoffs are as close as they can get to the real thing. One of the things that's real about them is they're for the rest of us, right? They bring the rest of us into the world of the artist, right? They allow us to participate in the fashion world, even if we can't afford the stuff that is paraded out in the runway.
克里斯托弗提出这样一个观点：这种给予椅子和服装等昂贵物品的保护实际上对消费者不利。因为对大多数人来说，山寨货就是他们能买到的最接近真品的东西。它们真实的一面在于它们是为我们其他人准备的，对吧？它们把我们其他人带入了艺术家的世界，对吧？它们让我们能够参与到时尚世界中，即使我们买不起那些在T台上展示的东西。
They allow us to participate in the world of industrial design, furniture, kitchen appliances, etc. Even if we can't afford the super expensive brands. That's democratizing. I think it makes the country prettier and more enjoyable. But for Greg, Emico knockoffs also make the country the whole planet worse by filling landfills with garbage chairs. All of our product is engineered to be made for the longest life possible. A knockoff is surely made to be sold, used, and thrown away. Great could probably still make nice chairs for less money, but it takes
它们让我们能够参与到工业设计、家具、厨房电器等的世界中。即使我们买不起超级昂贵的品牌。那是民主化的。我认为这让这个国家变得更美丽、更令人愉快。但对格雷格来说，Emico 的山寨货也通过用垃圾椅子填满垃圾填埋场，让整个国家、整个地球变得更糟糕。我们所有的产品都经过精心设计，以实现尽可能长的使用寿命。山寨货无疑是为了销售、使用和丢弃而制造的。格雷格可能仍然可以用更少的钱制造出漂亮的椅子，但这需要
77 steps to make a torpedo-proof chair. And a torpedo-proof chair will last 150 years. The goal is to produce something where it has the least impact environmentally all the way through and has the longest life. To me, that's the very best kind of product you could do. Greg genuinely cares about sustainability. I spent just a few days with him, but I know he thinks food tastes worse when it's served in disposable containers and that he travels with his own silverware. This is why he wishes he could use the law to go after all the knockoffs.
77 个步骤来制造一把防鱼雷的椅子。一把防鱼雷的椅子可以使用 150 年。目标是生产出一种在整个过程中对环境影响最小且寿命最长的产品。对我来说，那是你能做出的最好的产品。格雷格真心关切可持续发展。我和他只相处了几天，但我知道他认为用一次性容器盛装的食物味道更糟糕，而且他随身携带自己的餐具。这就是为什么他希望自己能利用法律打击所有的山寨货。
The look of likes and the almost looks likes, like the popular lightweight aluminum delta chair from Craten-Barrell. I showed him a photo of this chair. Is this a fake? Absolutely, a fake. What they've done here is they've they've put instead of three bars on the vertical back they put four bars instead of having a horizontal bar
那些长得像的和几乎长得像的，比如 Crate & Barrel 畅销的轻质铝制三角椅。我给他看了一张这把椅子的照片。这是假货吗？绝对是假货。他们在这里做的是，他们在垂直靠背上没有放三根杆子，而是放了四根杆子，而不是在底部有一根水平杆子
towards the bottom they take these four vertical bars and bring them all the way down to the seat bottom but it's the same tube shape it's bent the same way the legs are the same configuration the seat bottom has the bum dip in it the front legs have the taper This is made to look like an emigre chair Amazing Benjamin took me to a Creighton barrel in Manhattan to show me the chair and question So I think we have to go in this room. I came in here looking for it the other day And look what these bastards did with this knockoff. Look at that. They kept the welds on the top of the flat welds. Yes, the decorative welds. Oh my god, that is a
他们把这四根垂直杆一直延伸到座位底部，但它是相同的管状形状，弯曲方式相同，椅腿结构相同，座位底部有臀部凹槽，前腿有锥度。这是为了看起来像一把 Emico 椅子。太棒了。本杰明带我去了曼哈顿的一家 Crate & Barrel，向我展示那把有问题的椅子。所以我想我们得进这个房间。我前几天来这里找过它。看看这些混蛋对这个山寨货做了什么。看那个。他们把焊缝保留在扁平焊缝的顶部。是的，装饰性焊缝。天哪，那是一个
looks like a serious question. So the Creighton Barrel chair is different enough to avoid a lawsuit, but it retained those signature welds of the Emico chair to give it that handcrafted feel. But even if they mimic the welds, according to Greg, there will always be one key difference between the Emico chair and this one. It won't last, it's not designed to last as long as our chair is. Greg is fairly certain. It wouldn't pass the original test of being thrown off
看起来是个严肃的问题。所以 Crate & Barrel 的椅子与 Emico 椅子有足够的区别以避免诉讼，但它保留了 Emico 椅子的标志性焊缝，赋予其手工制作的感觉。但即使它们模仿了焊缝，根据格雷格的说法，Emico 椅子和这把椅子之间永远存在一个关键区别。它不会持久，它的设计寿命不会像我们的椅子那么长。格雷格相当确定。它无法通过从
that eighth story building. Of course, there's really only one way to find out. That helicopter, we're gonna wait for the helicopter. Now that I have you on my roof on the seventh floor with the knockoff Crateron barrel, I kind of think the ultimate test is throwing it off and see what happens. No way, no way. No, you're on your own for that one.
八楼扔下去的最初测试。当然，真的只有一个方法可以找出答案。那架直升机，我们要等直升机。既然我把你弄到了我屋顶的七楼，手里拿着 Crate & Barrel 的山寨货，我有点觉得终极测试就是把它扔下去看看会发生什么。没门，没门。不，你自己承担这个。
You do that on your show. There's no way I'm taking responsibility for that. Absolutely not. So to hear what happens next, you're gonna have to go to the theory of everything. You're gonna go to the theory of everything. You're not suing me. When a chair is designed specifically to be affordable and then it becomes expensive,
你在你的节目里这么做。我绝不为此承担责任。绝对不。所以要听接下来会发生什么，你得去听《万物理论》。你得去听《万物理论》。你可不能起诉我。当一把椅子被专门设计成价格实惠的，然后它变得昂贵，
and then affordable knockoffs are created, which is the real chair. Kurt Colstead and I talk more about fake chairs. After this. Charles and Ray Eames were two of America's most influential modern designers. And in the mid-1900s, they made all kinds of architecture, products, graphics, and films, and toys, and furniture. You've probably seen their iconic lounge chair. It's very distinctive. It features a molded plywood frame set on a metal base And it's usually topped with black leather upholstery. There are plenty of knockoffs of this chair and it's matching ottoman But Coulston is here to talk about another chair of theirs a more utilitarian chair like emico's that also gets copied a lot
接着又出现了价格实惠的山寨货，哪一把才是真正的椅子？稍后，我和库尔特·科尔斯特德将讨论更多关于假椅子的事。查尔斯和雷·埃姆斯是美国最具影响力的现代设计师中的两位。在 20 世纪中期，他们创作了各种建筑、产品、平面设计、电影、玩具和家具。你可能见过他们标志性的躺椅。它非常独特。它的特点是模压胶合板框架，安装在金属底座上，通常配有黑色皮革软垫。这款椅子和与之相配的脚凳有很多山寨货，但科尔斯特德在这里要讨论的是他们的另一把椅子，一把像 Emico 那样也被大量复制的更具实用性的椅子。
Charles Eames once said that their 1950s lounge chair was designed to be soft and cushy because he was sick of people complaining about how uncomfortable modern furniture was. And some of those complaints were pretty understandable in response to one of the Eames other best sellers designed a few years earlier, a series of molded fiberglass chairs. So I know this one and you've probably encountered it. I kind of think of it as the school chair. It's a, has metal legs that you can stack up and there's this main seat piece. It's molded into a curvy L shape.
查尔斯·埃姆斯曾说过，他们 20 世纪 50 年代的躺椅被设计得柔软舒适，因为他厌倦了人们抱怨现代家具是多么的不舒服。其中一些抱怨是相当可以理解的，这是对埃姆斯的另一款几年前设计的畅销产品——一系列模压玻璃纤维椅子的回应。所以我知道这款，你可能也遇到过。我有点把它看作是学校里的椅子。它有一套你可以叠起来的金属腿，还有一个主座件。它被模压成一个弯曲的 L 形。
And then there are variants that can have arms or no arms. It can have different legs, different styles of bases, all that kind of stuff. Yeah, and that modularity was a big selling point. Buyers could pick a base for the home or pick one for the office, you know, something more minimalist, or something more stylish. But the chairs weren't just designed to look nice.
然后还有带扶手或不带扶手的变体。它可以有不同的腿，不同风格的底座，诸如此类。是的，这种模块化是一个很大的卖点。买家可以为家里挑选一个底座，或者为办公室挑选一个，你知道的，更简约的风格，或者更时尚的风格。但这些椅子不仅是为了好看而设计的。
They were also meant to be affordable and functional. So they were low cost, easy to mass produce, easy to move around, easy to keep clean. And actually, the first prototype was built for an international competition for low-cost furniture design, which was hosted by the Museum of Modern Art in New York City. And so did it actually win this competition? Actually no. The chair took second place. But it's pretty good still. Yeah, and to be fair, there were, you know, three thousand of their entries or so.
它们还旨在兼顾实惠和功能性。因此它们成本低、易于大规模生产、易于搬运、易于保持清洁。事实上，第一个原型是为纽约现代艺术博物馆举办的低成本家具设计国际竞赛而制造的。那么它真的赢了这场比赛吗？其实没有。这把椅子得了第二名。但它依然很棒。是的，平心而论，你知道的，有大约三千件参赛作品。
And the jury reportedly liked that modular approach, but they may have taken off points because the prototype was made of stamped steel. And that's a tricky and expensive material to work with, takes these high pressures and high temperatures. So for mass production, they actually switched to fiber reinforced plastic. And because the chairs were made up of just a few pieces, they were easy to assemble too. And that sounds a lot different from the 77 step process. It's great. The aluminum, navy, and my co-chair. It really is. is they were easy to assemble too. And that sounds a lot different from the 77 step process. Great.
评审团据称喜欢这种模块化的方法，但他们可能因为原型是用冲压钢制成的而扣了分。那是一种棘手且昂贵的加工材料，需要承受高压和高温。因此为了大规模生产，他们实际上改用了纤维增强塑料。而且因为这些椅子仅由几个部件组成，所以组装起来也很容易。这听起来与 77 步的工艺大不相同。太棒了。铝制海军椅和我的 Emico 椅子。确实如此。而且这种简单性是刻意设计的。但这些不同的椅子实际上确实有共同点。山寨公司非常喜欢复制它们。根据我找到的一个消息来源，这些模压埃姆斯椅的变体之一——这款拥有所谓埃菲尔铁塔底座（由四条带有交叉金属连接器的腿组成）的椅子——实际上是当今世界上被复制最多的椅子之一。
The aluminum, navy, and my co-chair. It really is. And that simplicity is by design. But these different chairs do actually have something in common. Knock off companies love to make copies of them. And according to one source I found, one of these molded Eames chair variants, this one that has what's called the Eiffel Tower base, which is a set of four legs with these crisscrossing metal connectors, is actually one of the most copied chairs in the world today.
但如果它们被设计成买得起的，复制它们的动机是什么？获得 Vitra 官方授权的埃姆斯椅子其实售价超过 500 美元。你知道的，这和 Emico 海军椅差不多。老实说，考虑到 Vitra 网站上挂着的那个埃姆斯名言，我觉得这有点奇怪：以最低的价格为最多的人提供最好、最伟大的产品。也许真品真的质量高得多，但价格标签看起来还是很高。
But if they were designed to be affordable, what is the incentive to make copies of them? Eames shares that are officially licensed by Vitra actually sell for over $500. Which is, you know, the same ballpark as these Emico Navy chairs. And honestly, it seemed a little odd to me, given this Eames quote that Vitra has up on $500, which is, you know, the same ballpark has these emico navy chairs, right? And I was thinking a little odd to me, given this eames quote that Vietra has up on their website, getting the most of the best to the greatest number of people for the least. And maybe the real ones really are much higher quality, but the price tag just still seems really high.
那么这些复制品是违法的复制品、授权的复制品，还是怎么回事？嗯，因地而异。例如在英国，作品最初自创作之日起享有 25 年的保护期。但在 2016 年，他们修改了规则。他们将保护期延长至创作者死后 70 年。
And so are these copies, illegal copies, license, copy? What's the deal with them? Well, it varies by place. And in the UK, for instance, creations were originally protected up to 25 years from the date of creation. But in 2016, they changed the rules. And they extended coverage up to 70 years after the death of the creator.
当然，这改变了许多现代经典的法律地位，包括埃姆斯椅，还有阿恩·雅各布森的蛋椅、密斯·凡·德罗的巴塞罗那椅、勒·柯布西耶的 LC2 沙发、野口勇的玻璃桌。所以拥有模压埃姆斯椅版权的公司 Vitra 也极力推动了这一改变。这并不令人意外。因此，当椅子的保护期从创作后 25 年变为创作者死后 70 年时，人们是怎么说的？嗯，在英国，许多人看到这个消息后，趁着新法律生效前，抢购复制品。
And of course, that shifted the legal status of a lot of modern classics, including the Eames Chairs, but also Arnie Jacobson's Eggchair, Miesfanderos, Barcelona chair, La Corbusier's LC2 sofa, the San Maruguchi's class table. So Vietra, the company that owns the rights to the molded Eamschairs, really pushed for this change too. Which is not that surprising. So when chairs went from being protected for 25 years after its creation to 70 years after the death of the creator, what did people say? Well, in the UK, a lot of people saw the news and rushed out to buy replicas ahead of the new law-taking effect.
当 Aldi 开始宣传一双售价 40 英镑的“复古风格”埃菲尔椅时，它病毒式传播开来。各方都有不同的看法。一些人认为这些是埃姆斯原版令人发指的山寨货。但《卫报》的一位建筑和设计评论家为这些复制品进行了辩护，他问道，这难道不正是查尔斯·埃姆斯
And when Aldi started advertising a pair of, quote, retro style, Eiffel chairs for 40 pounds, it went viral. And there were opinions on all sides. Some argued that these were, you know, reprehensible knockoffs of Eams originals. But there's one architect in design critic who writes for the Guardian defended the copies, asking, isn't this exactly what Charles Eams
想要的吗？那么，你认为查尔斯和雷·埃姆斯会对这一切说些什么？我的意思是，我们显然永远不会确切知道，但鉴于他们的设计哲学，我真的不禁在想，也许在某种意义上，他们会把这些实惠的复制品看作是真实的而不是虚假的，因为大规模的可及性是他们最初设计意图的重要组成部分。所以我想这可能取决于埃姆斯会更看重什么，是这把椅子的形状还是它的用途。
would have wanted? And so, what do you think, Charles and Ray Eams would have said about all this? I mean, obviously we'll never know for sure, but given their design philosophies, I really just keep wondering if maybe they'd have seen these affordable copies as more real than fake in so sense, because mass accessibility was a big part of their original design intent. So I guess it just depends on maybe what Eames would have valued more, the shape of this chair or what it was made to do.
对，这也回到了这个问题：究竟是什么造就了一个设计？是物体的形状吗？是功能吗？是做它被设计要做的事吗？如果它被制成便宜的，但现在却很贵。我的意思是，在这种情况下，如果它被制成便宜的而现在却很贵，它就未能履行其被设计要做的其中一件事。对。
Right, and it comes back to this question too, of what makes a design? Is it the shape of the thing? Is it the function? Is it doing what it's designed to do? If it was made to be cheap, it is now expensive. I mean, then that case, it is failing to do one of the things it's designed to do if it was made to be cheap and is now expensive? I mean, in that case, it is failing to do one of the things it was designed to do. Right.
本周的 99% Invisible 由来自《万物理论》的本杰明·沃克和安德鲁·卡拉威制作。在我录制这段音频时，我仍然不知道本杰明是不是真的把那把椅子从屋顶上扔下去了。我不知道，我也不想知道。在我亲耳从本杰明的《万物理论》中听到之前，我绝不沾手。去那里寻找答案吧。我们的团队中，高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔塑造了这个故事，
99% invisible was produced this week by Benjamin Walker and Andrew Callaway from the theory of everything. As I record this, I still don't know if Benjamin actually threw that chair off his roof. I don't know, and I don't want to know. I want no part of it until I hear it for myself on Benjamin Walker's theory of everything. Mosy on over there for answers. From our team, senior producer Katie Mingle shaped this story,
肖恩·雷创作了音乐，谢里夫·优素福让它听起来很棒。团队的其他成员还有数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特德、高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔、乔·罗森伯格的艾维·特罗尔、薇薇安·李、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的 Radio Row 制作。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的成员，这是一个由
Sean Real made the music and Sharif Yusuf made it sound good. The rest of the team is digital director, Kurt Colesdez, senior editor, Delaney Hall, Avery Troll from the Joe Rosenberg Vivian Lee, Emmett Fitzgerald, Tarenaren Mazza and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of
播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚决独立的集体，请访问 radiotopia.fm。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该程序的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars 以及该节目 @99PI org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。但如果你想要《万物理论》的链接、我们的任何旧剧集或每隔几天发布的新设计文章，请前往 99pi.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
the most innovative shows in all of podcasting by the mall at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI orc. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want that link to the theory of everything, any of our old episodes and new articles about design that co-op every few days head on over to 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是Radiotopia.fm旗下播客界最具创意的节目之一。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我Roman Mars以及节目@99PI orc。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但如果你想要“万物理论”的链接、我们以往的任何节目，以及每隔几天就会合作发布的关于设计的新文章，请访问99pi.org。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。